as it was 20 years ago under a cloudless
sky
as it is every year america remembering
[Music]
the current president and two of his
predecessors and their first ladies at
ground zero
where the twin towers once stood
at the moment the first plane struck
silence
[Music]
and the reflections of those whose
family members died that day
as we carry these 20 years forward i
find sustenance and a continuing
appreciation for all of those
who
rose to be more than ordinary people
and a father's pride in his daughter's
selfless acts in the last moments of her
life
and then the names read by those who'd
loved and lost
each one its own very personal story
gordon m amith junior
edelmiro abad
marie rose abbad
dad
we miss you every day
our greatest gifts are your beautiful
grandchildren
they embody your kind spirit
warm heart
loving nature
and zest for life
continue to watch over us
and your family
20 years feels like an eternity but yet
it still feels like yesterday until we
meet again my love rest in peace
[Music]
they remembered two at the pentagon that
landmark to america's military might
itself targeted that day
[Music]
mary jane booth
and a reminder that 911 was a
declaration of war that america's forces
have been fighting ever since
it is our responsibility to remember
and it is our duty to defend democracy
we cannot know what the next 20 years
will bring
we cannot know what new dangers they
will carry
we cannot foresee what churchill once
called the original originality of
malice
but we do know that america will always
lead
and the bells rang at shanksville in
pennsylvania too where the fourth plane
was brought down by the heroism of its
passengers
wanda anita green
my dad
donald freeman green
the man whose presidency was defined by
that day
reflecting on the country's response
there was shock at the audacity audacity
of evil
and gratitude for the heroism and
decency that opposed it
in the sacrifice of the first responders
in the mutual aid of strangers
in the solidarity of grief and grace
the actions of an enemy revealed the
spirit of a people
and we were proud of our wounded nation
the man who took on that legacy added
his tribute his decisions mean this is
the first 9 11 anniversary with no
american troops in afghanistan
john philip napolitano
whatever the debate about that today was
about remembrance
only this week the remains of two more
victims of the 9 11 attacks were finally
formally identified
more than a thousand remain unidentified
twenty years on so many are still living
with the pain of what happened here greg
milam sky news new york